okay Donald Trump is not stopping the UH
continued I don't know penchant for
obsession with making completely
ridiculous and baseless comments and the
latest after I guess attempting to reset
his campaign by suggesting his
supporters kill Hillary Clinton his
latest accusation is that President
Barack Obama is actually the founder of
Isis now I know Louis you didn't know
that I didn't know that many in our
audience would be surprised to hear wait
a second Obama founded Isis but that is
exactly what Donald Trump said last
night added another one of these
completely laughable rallies where he
shows up looking a very strange shade of
orange with but bizarre notes and just
making statements that don't make sense
let's take a look at the video to say
Isis is honoring President Obama he is
the founder of Isis he's the founder of
Isis yeah okay he's the founder
he founded Isis and I would say the
co-founder would be crooked Hillary
Clinton right that immediately was met
with chance of lock her up by the crowd
did you notice Louis that it you can
actually see in the picture that's over
my shoulder this is not a lot of people
here and of course people on stage are
pretty pretty carefully selected right
here you will notice a black woman and
right here you will notice a black man
as we know Trump polling 0% among black
people statistically in some states like
Ohio uh talk about pandering huh well I
can tell you he doesn't look happy to be
there his facial expression and uh he
probably thought I'll just get paid to
do this because no one else will and
I'll sit here and I'll deal with this
and listen to trump uh no actual
evidence though that the people on stage
were being paid to lewis is being
facetious we don't want to be accused
lewis of suggesting those people were
paid they melt may well have been but we
just have no evidence to support I'm
just assuming that he was paid to be
here uh so so what is Trump suggesting
that the foreign policy decisions of
Barack Obama created Isis I guess that's
the sort of point because i would say
that in that case George Bush is the
founder of Isis now I I was gonna get to
that right because this is number one
this is not the first time that Trump is
connected Obama to Isis a couple of
months ago he tweeted an article from
right wing news website Breitbart which
said the Obama administration was
actively support supporting al-qaeda in
Iraq the terrorist group that became the
Islamic state so Donald Trump is
implying as Lewis says that the foreign
policy decisions of President Obama and
Hillary Clinton as President Obama
Secretary of State somehow created the
conditions or maybe even more directly
led to the creation of Isis of course
reasonable scholars a foreign policy and
reality as opposed to fantasy worlds
understand that the real single decision
that created a vacuum in the area that
led to the creation of Isis was george w
bush's hairbrained decision to go into
Iraq in 2003 based on the false pretense
that number one
Iraq had weapons of mass destruction and
number two there was some connection
between Iraq and the 911 attacks I've
said it before and I will say it again
if you support Donald Trump you were
either ignorant unstable or a genuinely
bad person but as I see this day after
day after day ice I do start to question
the broader intelligence or lack thereof
of the US as a nation and this isn't
sort of a comment Louis about individual
people but it's sort of about this
entire country because although
individuals voted for Donald Trump
somehow we've gotten to a place in the
United States of America in 2016 where
someone like Trump can even become the
nominee who still present essentially no
policy positions at these speeches and
says things like Obama founded Isis and
what about killing Hillary yeah III you
look at his supporters and I think we
all know that most countries all
countries are full of racist people
that's never going to change yeah just
up appealing to to xenophobic people is
is pretty easy to do um but let's face
it our education system is not that
great uh compared to other countries at
our level of development and that's what
that's what you get attribute a lot to
our education system and just generally
two decades and decades of of uh
corporations buying politicians and and
I mean when that happens it just it's
your your country just crumbles to sum
up Donald Trump has worked out how he
will defeat Isis as president but it's
sort of a secret until he's elected you
know because of national security and
stuff but he's gonna somehow do it
without sending in any US troops because
he was always against the Iraq war would
never do that although we know that he
actually told Howard Stern in 2002 he
was in favor of the Iraq war but he
never mentions that so I've actually put
together a sort of policy guide for what
it is that Donald Trump's plan for the
Middle East is it and we've had to infer
some of this so number one trumpet
cities against intervention in the
Middle East he has also said that
forcing regime change is bad in
overthrowing uh Gaddafi was bad although
he is on record in 2011 is having said
that he's in favor of over
gaddafi so a little bit of a conflict
there he's also said the Iraq war was
bad and that he never supported it
that's also a lie he told Howard Stern
in 2002 he's in favor of it and of
course we know that he will kill and
torture terrorists as well as their
families up but he's against
intervention in the Middle East and
lastly according to joe scarborough
based on a conversation he had with
someone who was in the room with Trump
during a foreign policy briefing Trump
is not quite clear on why we can't just
use nuclear weapons to solve all of
these problems to begin with so I can't
make heads or tails out of it Louis is
where I come away yeah it's uh he
doesn't have a plan he said before he's
going to get the best people so far he's
collected the worst people yeah maybe
it's easier to collect good people once
you're actually president shore and and
maybe they think Trump just isn't very
legitimate now pretty scary that he he
could be quite legitimate as as soon as
he's commander-in-chief none of this
stuff appeals to the Republicans who are
just more concerned with smaller
government and lower taxes and they
don't really like liberal politicians
right just because you don't like Obama
doesn't mean you think Obama created the
Islamic state and Donald Trump although
you would imagine he's trying to pivot
to appeal to more people in the
electorate the idea that maybe Hillary
should be killed or her just judges
should be killed the people she would
pick or that Obama founded the Islamic
state it's actually appealing to a
narrow and narrow narrower and narrower
group of American voters and we're
seeing that reflected in the polls if
I'm wrong about any of this let me know
i'm on twitter at d pakman warby parker
is offering a free five day home try-on
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / TDPS I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the sales person sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked
the Mon in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing